hoy hablaron el canciller de nicaragua y
los ministros de ambiente de guatemala
el salvador paraguay y uruguay los tres
países centroamericanos pidieron que se
declaré a la región y al caribe como
zonas altamente vulnerables al cambio
climático porque además el ministro de
medioambiente guatemalteco recordó que
de los 10 países más afectados por
desastres climáticos en la última década
3 son centroamericanos no hubo ningún
anuncio importante en sus discursos pero
todos los ministros pidieron que que los
países más emisores se hagan cargo y
responsables del dinero que ellos deben
a los países menos emisores y que
precisamente sus países son responsables
de un porcentaje ínfimo de las emisiones
de gases de efecto invernadero
pidieron que sean coherentes entre lo
que dicen y hacen y que esos fondos que
llevan prometiendo desde el 2009 lleguen
y lleguen de manera rápida algunas
curiosidades en los discursos el
ministro de guatemala hizo su discurso
en inglés y el ministro del salvador
además que su país es pionero en la
tecnología de la escrito monedas y que
la tecnología del blogs en que es en la
que se basa bitcoin podría ser muy útil
en lo que es el mercado de carbonos que
es uno de los temas más peliagudos aquí
en las negociaciones climáticas el
canciller de nicaragua hizo mención a
las elecciones que se llevaron a cabo el
pasado domingo 7 de noviembre y las
calificó de justas y soberanas y
finalmente destacó que el ministro de
paraguay finalizó su discurso en guaraní
y fue el único de todos los líderes
latinoamericanos que hablaron que hizo
mención a la población indígena de su
país